[Music]
happy birthday daddy mac
well that one's wrapped up so nice it
must be from frank
electric shoe polisher next
i never knew why daddy was so mean to
uncle frank he was the kind of person i
wanted to be
smart and funny and considerate you're
going to be the person you decide to be
are you going to be the person everyone
else tells you all you get to choose
can i come visit you sometime
hi i'm frank smith oh my god beth nice
meeting you
frank tell me you're coming that's
because he doesn't know he doesn't know
oh well okay it's gonna be very exciting
how do you know uncle frank he's my
roommate
[Music]
never known anybody who was gay before
of course you had cloud director of
church
mr jersey but he's so what religious
[Music]
you need me for this you know you do
no wally you're not coming we can take
turns driving are you the stupidest man
alive
obviously look who i'm with this isn't
sometimes you always know you were gay
but always
i always knew i was different
what's wrong wally
oh hey you forgot your razor you rented
a car
isn't it snazzy
[Music]
i'd appreciate it if you didn't tell
anyone in the family about me
you want to stay by yourself in the
motel uncle frank's staying there too
so is wally who's wally what is the
relationship
between the two of you and the young
lady over there
oh she my niece i'm his nephew that
doesn't sound right
that sounds wronger and wrong you're not
going to run away from this your whole
life
you need to be part of your family i
don't want to be a part of my family so
when you told me i should be what i want
to be
that was just [ __ ] that conversation
changed my life
[Music]
huh
[Music]
you